I'm gonna go check the traps I'll be
back
love you too in Kowalik warming
temperatures signal the end of the
hailstones winter harvest before they
return to Norvik they have one last
chance at trapping fur and hunting meat
for the spring
the weather is so bad up on top of the
mountains lately that we've been forced
to stay down low and down low here
there's usually a lot of links so we
sent link straps all right take it in
locked up these are the rings of the
crank either the crank is out of sync or
I've got no piston pieces or holding it
together I'll tell you what could really
be worse is that I could have been up in
the mountains or I could have been 10
miles I'm just around the corner we just
call it lucky today whatever look this
is but I really don't want to do is be
broken down when the Carib will get here
because that's when all the fur arrives
it's when all the meat is here it's one
of our most productive times in the
spring if we lose out on that and we
have to buy food at the store for an
exorbitant amount of money
what's up but you know day when you
crash like me no how come you're walking
I think it's my crank maybe a piston
skirt maybe their rings maybe another
crank man that duck well I'll make two
into one that's my plan after a recent
crash minor field repairs were made to
Agnes his snow machine but with one
machine down they must now get the other
in full working condition so what's the
shorter cut my gas tank on your ride or
your engine in my ride which one would
be easier exactly so since I've been
walking ain't got nothing else to think
about
since my machines burned up and hers has
a good engine and will run I'm gonna go
straighten out her handlebar and I'm
gonna take her machine and go drag my
machine back here one or the other I may
end up with a working ride
you know this is how we live we've been
doing this for 25 years when things
break down we tried to keep the ball
rolling we know our alternatives and we
try to switch those alternatives so this
is work stop yep
this is junket there was a moment
because it doesn't run make sure you
look beautiful
okay okay thing mine and your rides are
the same yep
you